hi dr. Wallach how you doing okay sure
how can we help you good
I'm a 65 year old man pretty good shape
60 180 but my question is I've got some
toenail fungus and I've tried topical
stuff and nothing seems to work so
that's what I'm talking about okay any
other problems diabetes no respiratory
problems arthritis no I'm very good
shape okay all right well first of all
to get your immune system going and give
your body what it needs what would you
give a hundred eighty pound guys
Charmaine who just needs a general
program to support his immune system
well just for general maintenance I
would give him two healthy start packs
and I would also add the vitamin d3 and
I'd also add the killer biotic okay kill
her body could take two bottles a months
and take three of those twice a day and
that's eight herbs which will support
your immune system and two of the eight
also have the capacity killed
fungus and bacteria and yeast and
viruses but so char what would you give
mark to put topically on his toes
I give them colloidal silver
yeah colloidal silver I'd go ahead and
take a dropper full and say an ounce of
water or maybe even neat just a hundred
percent to our colloidal silver okay and
you go ahead and soak a cotton ball with
it and soak the nails the cuticle and
leave that cotton ball is wet with the
colloidal silver on it for like five
minutes that keep that area wet with the
colloidal silver and then after you
shower I would go ahead and put the pure
works either the foam or the spray on
your toes also the nails and the toes in
between the toes and you want to really
when you wash your socks you want to be
shirts and your slippers and things like
that for sure your socks you want to
wash them with bleach make sure you're
going to kill any bugs that might be in
there you do not want to wash your socks
with your underwear or your undershirts
and your your undershirt because
things that cause fungus infections near
toenails can cause fungus infection
everyplace else oh you got to be careful
there and so you got to really be after
this it might take a couple of months
two three four or five six months for
that damaged nail to grow out okay so
this is gonna be a process but you need
to really be on this because the fungus
in your toes can go everywhere so don't
wash your socks with any of your other
clothes okay
give us a call every couple of weeks so
let us know how it's going and it'll be
good testimony if you follow the rules
here you'll be a good testimony because
people is very common for people to get
toenail fungus